evaluating policy or the effectiveness
of a social intervention
requires a reliable control group not
affected by that intervention
but where can you find a suitable
control if everybody is affected
in fact various techniques can be used
to identify a control group
for instance it may be possible to
compare subjects which are at different
stages of implementation or to compare
groups that have been exposed to
different levels of the intervention
known as intensities of treatment let's
look at some examples
consider a directive affecting all eu
member states
countries may adopt this directive at
different times so those who have yet to
adopt it can be used as a control group
for countries which have already done so
this can be done using a difference
indifference approach comparing outcome
of the countries who
already adopted the directive and ones
who did not yet adopt it before
and after the directive was established
or consider an
ongoing training scheme offered to all
unemployed people
individuals who have yet to begin their
training may comprise a control group
for those already participating in it
this can be achieved using dynamic
matching which compares individuals
sharing similar characteristics
finally consider an eu-wide program
which provides
different amounts of funding to
different regions the outcomes in each
region can be related to the
degree of funding identifying a
dose-response
relationship this can be done using
generalized propensity score matching
are you working on policy evaluation for
the eu
or its member states the competence
center on microeconomic evaluation
or ccme can help you to identify the
best methods for evaluating projects and
initiatives
discover more about the competence
center and its resources
on our website